[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild
wir waren dort glaube ich mit 40 50
Personen wir versteckten uns und fährt
barrikadierten die Fenster und Türen und
alles andere wir verschlossen die Tür
und dann warteten wir
hatten Schüsse und nach kurzer
Zeitschritte die näher kamen
das ist Miriam den Moment den die junge
Frau hier gerade beschreibt das ist der
Moment der ihr Leben verändern wird die
damals 16-Jährige kauert in einer Schule
und versteckt sich vor einem Mann und
seinen tödlichen Schüssen vor einem
Attentäter der gerade dabei ist ein
Blutbad auf einer kleinen Insel in
Norwegen anzurichten
nur ein Stück über meinen Kopf ein
[Musik]
nur ein Meter entfernt
die Geräusche der Telefone die
klingelten waren so laut
wenn sie ausschalten mussten
schickte meinen Eltern also eine
Nachricht und schrieb ihn dass ich sie
liebe und dann musste ich mein Handy
ausschalten und warten
am 22 juli 2011 schaut die ganze Welt
fassungslos auf Norwegen der
Rechtsextremist Anders spray-weg zündet
zuerst eine Bombe im Regierungsviertel
der norwegischen Hauptstadt Oslo und
richtet dann ein Massaker auf der Insel
Ute ja an
Augenzeugen Miriam die er gerade gehört
habt die überlebt das Attentat mehr als
70 Menschen tun das aber nicht
am 12 Jahrestag dieser Anschlag Serie
widmen wir uns heute bei Tatort
Deutschland diesen verhängnisvollen Tag
und gehen der Frage nach wie konnte es
überhaupt so weit kommen
mein Name ist Mirko Kasimir und ich bin
Toni Heyer hallo zusammen unser Gast
heute ist bildchef Reporter Peter hell
seit dem ersten Tag berichtete über das
Attentat in Norwegen war einer der
ersten Journalisten vor Ort und
recherchierte über Anders Breivik
norwegen hat seine Unschuld verloren
Norwegen das muss man sich vorstellen
ist so ein friedliches Land also die
haben mit Anschlägen eigentlich nie
etwas zu tun gehabt im Gegensatz zu
anderen Ländern wo zu diesem Zeitpunkt
halt viel islamistischer Terror auch
ausgeübt wurde und dann passiert so eine
Anschlagserie mit 77 Toten wo eben auch
gezielt Jagd auf junge Menschen gemacht
worden ist das hatte eine Qualität die
hat es in Europa eigentlich so noch nie
gegeben aber bevor wir auf diesen 22
juli 2011 schauen müssen wir erst einmal
ins Jahr 1979 zurückgehen in diesem Jahr
kommt anders bei Weg auf die Welt der
Mann der diese schreckliche
Anschlagsserie plante und aus
ganz unauffällig und beinahe völlig
unaufhaltsam Anders sperring Breivik
wird in eine Mittelstandsfamilie geboren
seine Mutter ist Krankenschwester sein
Vater Diplomat die Eltern lassen sich
früh scheiden breiweg wächst bei seiner
Mutter und ihrem neuen Mann auf
ralvix Mutter ist psychisch krank und
geht wenig liebevoll mit ihrem Sohn um
anders bei Wick ist anders als andere
Kinder er wird schon als Kleinkind
verhaltensauffällig zeigt wenig
Emotionen Feind nicht previx Mutter ist
maßlos überfordert mit ihrem Sohn
Psychologen empfehlen ihr sogar anders
ins Heim zu geben aber es passiert gar
nichts anders Breivik bleibt bei seiner
Mutter bei den Ämtern und Ärzten Gerät
die dysfunktionale Familie in
Vergessenheit breivik hat wenige Freunde
gilt als Einzelgänger und Verlierer
dafür verbringt der Norweger viel Zeit
im Internet breiweg spielt
Computerspiele und treibt sich auf
rechten propagandaseiten herum
zwischenzeitlich ist Breivik sogar
stellvertretender Leiter eines
Ortsverbands der Partei aber nach
mehreren Jahren verlässt er die
sogenannte Fortschrittspartei wieder
sein Grund die Rechtspopulisten seien
ihm zu angepasst zu sehr Teil des
Establishments und das hat an der
spreeweg mit so vielen anderen Dingen zu
hassen gelernt denn über die Jahre
radikalisiert sich freiwillig stetig
sein Feindbild ist der Islam der
Rechtsextremist denkt der Islam wolle
Europa unterwandern außerdem wäre seiner
Meinung nach eine westliche Elite von
Multikulturalisten und kulturmachisten
den Moslems dabei zu Diensten breivik
ist der Auffassung eine christlich
konservative Avantgarde müsste aufstehen
und gegen diese Unterwanderung Kämpfen
bei Weg versteht sich als einer dieser
Kämpfer als Tempelritter der Attentate
verüben müsse dadurch die Macht
ergreifen und so die Muslime aus Europa
verjagen könnte dass wir heute so genau
verstehen können welche Kranken
gedankenbreite hatte das liegt unter
anderem daran dass er alles in einem
mehr als 1.500 Seiten lang Manifest
aufgeschrieben hat an einem
juli-nachmittag verschickt der
Rechtsextremist genau dieses verstörende
Manifest an mehrere Journalisten und
Politiker die letzten Worte in diesem
Manifest lauten ich gehe davon aus dass
das mein letzter Eintrag sein wird heute
ist Freitag der 22 juli 12 Uhr
[Musik]
Breivik sendet es also 90 Minuten bevor
seine blutige Anschlagsserie beginnt und
das Leben so vieler unschuldiger für
immer verändern wird es ist 15 Uhr
Überwachungskameras Filmen wie sich an
der spreeweg in einem VW Transporter dem
Regierungsviertel nähert im Stauraum des
Autos befinden sich 950 Kilo Sprengstoff
die Bombe hat der Rechtsextremist selbst
gebaut um 15:17 Uhr parkt Breivik den
weißen Transporter unweit des Sitzes ist
damaligen Ministerpräsidenten Jens
Stoltenberg die Kameras zeichnen auf wie
Breivik aus dem Auto steigt und sich vom
Transporter entfernt er trägt einen
Schutzhelm und eine Uniform 8 Minuten
später explodiert
sie zerstört Gebäudefassaden und Autos
das Osloer Regierungsviertel gleicht
einem Kriegsschauplatz Rauch Trümmer
Chaos
die Bombe reist acht Menschen in den Tod
10 weitere werden schwer verletzt
teilweise durch die umherfliegenden
Glassplitter
Norwegen Europa die ganze Welt steht
unter Schock die Bild wird am Morgen
danach Titeln Terror in Oslo
schockierende Augenzeugen Berichte auf
der Straße liegen tausend Menschen
unmittelbar nach der Explosion sprechen
weltweit Politiker wie Präsident Obama
und Bundeskanzlerin Merkel Norwegen ihre
Anteilnahme aus
beiwegsbombe ist das erste Attentat auf
eine europäische Regierungszentrale ja
und die Sorge ist groß dass noch mehr
Bomben in Norwegen explodieren könnten
in der Bild-Zeitung erzählt eine Zeugin
die Polizei sagt sie sollen so schnell
wie möglich Oslo verlassen sie hätten
Angst dass es noch eine Explosion geben
wird
die Innenstadt wird komplett abgeriegelt
Menschen flüchten aus der Stadt die die
bleiben die die verlassen ihre Wohnungen
nicht die Sicherheitsbehörden gehen
zuerst von einem islamistischen
Terroranschlag aus denn im Juli 2011
sind die Anschläge in New York London
und Madrid noch keine zehn Jahre her
dass ein Norweger eine Bombe zündet das
kann sich hier keiner vorstellen
reigweg nutzt das Chaos und die
Ungewissheit
Überwachungskameras halten fest wie er
nach der Explosion in einen anderen
Wagen steigt und losfährt denn sein
eigentliches Ziel hat Breivik noch vor
sich das bis dahin noch völlig
unbekannte ja
bitte ja ist ca 40 km von Oslo entfernt
die Insel liegt im fünf größten
Binnensee Norwegens vom Himmel sieht sie
aus wie ein kleiner grüner Fleck im
blauen Wasser
bitte ja ist keine 11 Hektar groß eine
breitesten Stelle müsste gerade mal
etwas mehr als 500 Meter also wirklich
sehr sehr klein der Großteil der Insel
ist bewaldet viele Tannen ragen in den
Himmel am Ufer ein langer Steg ins kalte
Wasser Gebäude gibt es auf Güter direkt
hinter dem Doc steht das weiß
angestrichene Haupthaus
am höchsten Punkt der Insel direkt neben
dem Zeltplatz befindet sich das größte
Gebäude die Cafeteria im Speisesaal
stehen Tische und Bänke an der Wand
hängt ein großer Kalender der die
geplanten Aktivitäten für den Tag
auflistet die Insel ist im Privatbesitz
der norwegischen Arbeiterpartei au.f
Parteifreunde können hier in den
Sommerferien ins Ferienlager fahren ihre
Tage mit Fußballspielen oder Karaoke
singen verbringen manchmal kommen auch
Politiker auf die Insel
abends sitzen die Camp Bewohner
gemeinsam am Feuer und grillen oder
Backen lecker Stockbrot
am 22 juli 2011 sind insgesamt 564
Betreuer und Jugendlicher auf der Insel
nachdem in Oslo breivik's Bombe
explodiert melden sich viele besorgte
Eltern bei ihren Kindern im Ferienlager
aber hier auf dem friedlichen Ute Jahr
wegen sich die Camp-Teilnehmer in
Sicherheit doch was keiner weiß während
die Jugendlichen ihre Eltern
beschwichtigen ist Breivik schon ganz
nah gegen 17 Uhr erreicht er das
Festland gegenüber der Insel er hat sich
als Polizist verkleidet und will mit
einer Fähre Nachfahren
gegenüber einem Fährmann behauptet
Breivik er würde die Camp-Teilnehmer
über den Anschlag in Oslo informieren
der Rechtsextremist trägt eine
dunkelblaue Polizeiuniform eine
kugelsichere Weste eine Glock und ein
halbautomatisiertes Gewehr um 17 Uhr
zwei Stunden nach der Explosion in Oslo
betritt brevic die inselhütte ja er
läuft den langen Steg zum Haupthaus
hinunter und eröffnet unmittelbar das
Feuer
braves ersten Opfer sind die Camp
Leiterin und ein Wachmann der
Stiefbruder von Kronprinzessin Mette
Marit in den Verhören wird Breivik
später sagen dass ihm diese Morde wie in
Zeitlupe vorkam die Morde danach die
fehlen dem Rechtsextremisten leichter
wenige hundert Meter entfernt am
Zeltplatz wissen die Jugendlichen noch
nichts von beiweg und den tödlichen
Schüssen sie hören diese zwar nehmen
anfangs jedoch an es handelt es sich um
ein Feuerwerk oder um platzende Balance
doch Sekunden später beginnt
Jugendlichen zu realisieren das auf sie
geschossen wird das ist für sie jetzt um
Leben und Tod geht die Camp-Teilnehmer
wollen fliehen versuchen überall auf
dieser kleinen inselschutz zu suchen
manche Rennen in die Insel Cafeteria
wollen sich hier vor Breivik verstecken
aber vergeblich
um 17 Uhr 27 Uhr betritt der
Rechtsextremist mit vorgehaltener Waffe
das Holzhäuschen und eröffnet das Feuer
präzise und ruhig schießt er auf die
tempowohner
13 von ihnen werden hier ermordet
quer über die Insel und unerbittlich
setzt breiweg sein Blutbad fort viele
der Betreuer und Jugendlichen versuchen
sich in den Wald zu flüchten oder Rennen
weiter zum Ufer der Insel bist Reporter
Peter hell berichtet was Überlebende ihm
nach dem Attentat erzählen über die
ganze Insel so beschrieb uns ein Zeuge
waren die Schreie der Kinder und
Jugendlichen zu hören die eben
panikartig versucht haben zu flüchten
alle sind sie weg von den Schüssen hin
zu den Ufer Böschungen haben sich hinter
Baumstämme versteckt haben sich versucht
an die Küste an die Ufer zu retten viele
sind ins Wasser gesprungen sind
verzweifelt haben versucht die fast ein
Kilometer entfernte Festland zu
erreichen
gnadenlos feuert breiig selbst auf Camp
Teilnehmer die im Wasser versuchen als
Festland zu schwimmen Anwohner des
gegenüberliegenden Ufers fahren mit
Ihrem Boot in den kugelhagen ziehen die
Flüchtenden Jugendlichen aus dem kalten
Wasser
doch viele Camp-Teilnehmer schaffen es
nicht nicht einmal ins Wasser
am steinigen Ufer uterias findet Breivik
viele seiner Opfer ja das ist wirklich
furchtbar die kippbewohner haben also
offensichtlich kaum eine Chance Breivik
zu entkommen ob sie sich ins Wasser
flüchten oder sich versuchen in Gebäuden
zu verstecken egal er findet sie alle
und genau das ist ja das Problem das ist
so perfide auf einer Insel weil es keine
Möglichkeit gibt zu fliehen also die
einzige Möglichkeit auf Hilfe die kann
ja nur aus der Luft kommen oder übers
Wasser und bis die dann mal endlich da
sind bis auch jemand mitbekommt was da
los ist solange sind die alle komplett
ausgeliefert und genau dieser sehnte
Hilfe die kommt halt erstmal nicht und
deshalb kann Breivik sein Blut Baden
aller sehen Ruhe weiter anrichten aber
warum kommt diese Hilfe nicht und wie
wird Breivik schlussendlich gestoppt und
vor allem welches Urteil erwartet
Breivik nach seinem Blut Bart und genau
das hört ihr in der nächsten Folge hier
bei Tatort Deutschland